good morning heck it's tuesday a little
bit of a stressful day around here
31 years after having their stadium
taken away from them afc wimbledon are
back home
at last playing their first game today
at the new plow lane stadium it's an
incredible accomplishment a stadium
built and
owned by the fans i'm so excited
there's also an election if you're
eligible to vote in the united states
please do you can find your polling
place and more at vote.org okay
i'm gonna make a video about something
else okay so back in march we did a live
show fundraiser that i did not at the
time realize was going to be my last
experience of the old normal and
after the show someone whose name
unfortunately i do not remember came up
to me and handed me
this an art project called alaska for
looking
this is the entire text of my first
novel looking for alaska
but rearranged into alphabetical order
so it begins with all the numbers in the
book
and then quite a lot of a's because
apparently
i love an indefinite article and so just
before the world i thought i knew turned
into a strange
dizzying uncanny version of itself
someone handed me
a novel i thought i knew turned into a
strange
dizzying uncanny version of itself i
last read looking for alaska in 2004
when i was
26 years old i do not enjoy reading my
work after it has been published partly
because
it's very frustrating not to be able to
change anything and partly because you
know there are lots of other books i
would like to read and so 16 years later
i don't really feel qualified to comment
on looking for alaska but alaska for
looking is fascinating
like for example here at the end of the
letter h it reads hygienic
hyperventilating hypothetical hysteria i
i i i i which would not be a bad title
for my autobiography
like hygienic hyperventilating
hypothetical hysteria is
my overwhelming response to 2020. it's
just such a good line it's one of those
lines that you wish you had written
until you realized that you did write it
just not in the right order
in fact reading a book alphabetized
leads to all kinds of wonderful
combinations how
again leads into against or wrong
interrupt or lonely into long
seeing the book this way it's a story of
huddled hugs and
smirking smoke and then there are the
little things i was reminded of like
when writing alaska i was obsessed with
symmetry
the number of days in the first part of
the book had to be exactly equal to the
number of days in the second part of the
book and so on but i also did all these
silly little things to please this weird
worship of symmetry like having the word
remembered appear
exactly one more time than the word
forgotten and it was nice to be reminded
of that if only because 16 years later i
can
celebrate not being quite so beholden to
symmetrical obsession to read a book
alphabetically is to understand its
preoccupations but not
its narrative like in alaska for looking
i have no idea who anyone
is or what happens to them but i can
tell the story is about school
and before and after and labyrinths
and that's actually not so different
from how stories survive in my head like
i don't remember the plot of most of the
books i've read only
how they made me feel and why they
mattered to me
now of course an alphabetized book
doesn't tell you the whole story but
reading through this i did feel like it
was telling me a story
a story about me and me and me
and you and you and you and time
and time and time the end of alaska for
looking
will not make sense to people who
haven't read the book but if you have
you'll know how strangely lovely and
wrenching it is
the alphabetized book ends like this zen
zero zipped zoo zoo
zoo zoo which is not such a bad way of
saying goodbye to that story
hank i now return to my hygienic
hyperventilating hypothetical hysteria
i will see you on friday this video
contains a clue just like all my recent
videos do the clue leads to a secret
live stream and was repeated four times
toward the end of this video